Back in lesson four we learned
that the Android runtime
will kill apps with
no visible activities
in order to free resources
needed by the foreground app.
But what if your app has tasks
that need to continue
when the activity isn't visible?
Things like downloading files,
uploading photos, or playing music.
Well, there's an application
component for that.
Services.
We've already introduced
activities, content providers,
broadcast receivers and intents.
Services are the final piece
to the Android app component puzzle.
You start services
much like you do activities,
by passing in an intent
to a startService call.
And you can stop
services the same way.
By calling stopService
and passing in the name
of the service
you want to stop.
Unlike activities, services have
no user interface
and they run at a higher priority
than background activities.
This means that an app
with a running service,
is less likely to be killed
by the runtime
in order to free resources
for the foreground activities.
In fact, by default, the system
will attempt to restart services
that are terminated before
they are stopped from within the app.
This is reflected in
this simplified lifecycle.
Compared to activities,
services are designed
to execute longer running tasks
that shouldn't be interrupted.
Typically, you'll only need to
override the onStartCommad handler,
which is where you begin
the background task
you wish to execute.
But notice that there are no handlers
for monitoring changes in state,
to reflect the app moving
to the background.
This is because the
running service itself,
sends a signal to the framework,
that the containing app should
be considered higher priority
than other apps in the background
that don't have running services.
In some cases your service
may performing a task,
that while not having UI,
can't be interrupted
without interfering
with the user experience.
For example, playing music
or helping with in car navigation.
In these cases you can
indicate that your server
should be considered to be
running in the foreground
by calling startForeground.
You'll notice that this call
takes in a notification.
This will be displayed,
and can't be dismissed
until the service has stopped
or you call stopForeground.
You'll learn more about notifications
a little later, with Dan.
But for now, note that a foreground
service runs at the same priority
as a foreground activity.
Making it nearly impossible
for the runtime to kill
in order to free resources.
Now you may be thinking to yourself,
I could save a lot of trouble
dealing with lifecycles,
just by creating long running
or even foreground services.
Well, I grew up along
the coast in Australia,
so I learned young that
swimming against the current
is exhausting and ultimately futile.
In this case, that means
making it more difficult
for the system to manage resources,
ultimately leading to
a worse user experience.
Swim with the current.
Use foreground services
only when and for as long as
absolutely necessary.
And stop all service
as as quickly as possible.
It's also important to note
that like activities and receivers,
services run on the main thread.
So you'll need to use
a background thread or think task
to execute the long running tasks
you wish to do within your service.
To make life easier, you can
use the intent service class.
Which implements the most common
best practice pattern, for using intents,
which are executed within a service.
It creates a queue of incoming intents,
passed in when start service is called.
These are then processed sequentially
on a background thread,
within the onHandleIntent handler,
within your intent service implementation.
When the queue is empty,
the service self terminates
until a new intent is received,
and the process begins again,
Services are a powerful tool
and it's important to understand
how you can use them,
but in practice there's often
a framework alternative
to rolling your own
service implementation.
Whether that be an intent service
for executing background tasks
or the sync adapter which you'll
learn about later in this lesson.
Perfect for performing background
data synchronization.